engine was still on I was in the car
behind the wheel I was about to back up
and then a cop pulls him right behind me
and locks me in no way and then comes
over he's like and I'm like oh my God
[Music]
so I you know a lot about Long Island
yeah no
I would break your improv I don't know
how to do whatever it is man yes I know
a lot about Long Island there's a
there's a woman in Long Island who uh
pulled a 40 million dollar scheme what
do you think a Long Island woman would
do to pull a 40 how do you do that 40
million dollars a psychic medium or some
[ __ ] that's pretty good for 40 million
dude it's like it's hot business boy
yeah dude some [ __ ] spiritual
Crystal related type [ __ ] I bet you
that's a big industry that's a really
good guess actually the crystals are hot
bro crystals are hot they sell those
like throw some horoscopes in there boom
millions of dollars throw some
characteristics in there dude Crystal
stuff is pretty bad you see on Tick Tock
you see on Tick Tock they got those
Crystal [ __ ] lives those live streams
where they're just like in a bucket full
of crystals and then you like get a grab
bag and those things are going 24 hours
a day dude I know it's [ __ ] but I'll
watch and I'll be like I bet it'll work
for me you think crystals really work no
dude but the way they sell it the way
they sell it is like oh you just want to
[ __ ] believe this one's like Thanos
at home with crystals
I'm Gonna Be Rich yeah you know it's
funny it's like even people who believe
in crystals have another subset of like
things that um make crystals unusable
that you're like what because I was
walking by a crystal table at the market
with a friend of mine that does believe
in them and I was like aren't you
interested to get some of these they
look great she was like they've been out
all day of course there's no more power
yeah the energy gets sucked out of them
or the blue energy I knew a girl who
used to put her crystals out at night
when it was a full moon because the moon
would recharge them it's true but it's
true though it is true
you try to dunk on her and you just got
dunked on in front of everybody your
views are so fluctuate I can't give up
idiot but that's the thing about the
spiritual [ __ ] like that like you can't
make anybody there's there's all these
made up rules that I'm putting crystals
out of your [ __ ] window at night when
you don't know about now watch I I do it
only on half Moons dude okay I don't
know would you grapple a dude covered in
crystals no that's that's too much
energy
[Laughter]
he's a quartz belt yeah there's no
[ __ ] no chance all right so it's not
Crystal based this game no crystals in
opioids
that's also really good sounds like you
no Long Island it's not just a guess
it's not opioid based either it's not
she didn't flip houses or something no
houses no drugs no crystals no woo-woo
[ __ ] at all no like that what's moving
like weird oh no no psychic stuff is it
demographic for women well who she scams
it's a little bit surprising is it just
Herbalife
it's just a pyramid scheme classic is it
Mary Kay so let's just say this she's a
it's it's a long island woman she's
white
oh I already have assumed but what she
did is kind of more of a reputably an
Asian thing she did
so okay okay oh so she just uh changes
money laundered in front of a [ __ ]
restaurant for like 10 years giving away
our family secrets if she does nails
that's it can that's all you got you can
make a lot of tips man you can make 40
million dollars with the nails
or fake uh fake purses
because that's big business there it is
counterfeit merchandise big big Bingo
she's a 31 year old Long Island woman
she had 40 million dollars in
counterfeit Gucci Chanel Prada and other
high-end labels selling it out of her
own Boutique in Long Island dude that
bit that market is [ __ ] insane was it
only Chinese people buying the
merchandise because then that's good I
think that the there's nothing wrong no
it's like Karma it's for everybody Karma
so she would take she would take Chinese
made sweatshirts like a 10 sweatshirt
flip it for five grand whoa one
sweatshirt so she probably just took a
Sharpie out wrote like Balenciaga on it
and then sold it to a bunch of like no
she did the classic she did the um she
had her own press that made the label so
she'll make the fake labels and she had
her own um you know like the screen
printing she was manufacturing herself
that's tight yeah that's why I'm like
that's super illegal yeah yeah but what
was the quality of the goods
like were they high quality imagine it's
better than the actual dude because she
handmade it it might have been yeah I
mean 40 million is a lot 40 million yeah
how long does this but they're saying 40
million in merchandise they're not
saying like all sold right yeah they she
had 22 heat press machines in her shop
nah she doing big business yeah she was
doing numbers she was doing it for a
while it doesn't say how long she got
away with it but dude she was selling
shirts for sweaters for five thousand
dollars they probably don't want to say
how long she was doing it because she
was doing that [ __ ] for a while it was
definitely a long time and then that's
on them that they didn't catch her and
that's a great place to jump in if
you're like she gotta wait for 10 years
I could just do it for five yeah and
just and just cut it yeah yeah that's
that's why I was like okay so
it's yes it's morally wrong but it's
like promised to her because she
actually put in the work and she
actually sold these things and so she
did the work to make the money but it's
just not her brand and I bet no one that
actually bought the [ __ ] gave a [ __ ]
until this story came out probably
people even noticed because if they
believed that it was Gucci until they
died it's like okay yeah you know or
even if they found out now that this
[ __ ] is fake they're not telling anybody
that they got it from this right like
who the [ __ ] is gonna do that yeah and
nobody's if they found out it was fake
they wouldn't tell their friends oh I
think it's fake because then that's what
I just said in a different way that's
why you guys are a good team
did you guys ever buy fake fake [ __ ]
when you were in high school [ __ ] yeah
yeah me too
yeah my dad brought it home yeah the
liquor store was like oh this is fire
but then I'll look on the other side
like oh this [ __ ] is fake this is gilded
yeah yeah back in the day my daddy said
he would go to China a lot and he would
come back with the the uh the pirated
PlayStation ooh and then he would just
buy all the games for like hell of cheap
obviously like most of them wouldn't
work but the ones that did work worked
okay they worked
pirated PlayStation yeah dude it was
wild pirated as in like it was unlocked
to play like discs that you can burn
yeah like games
it was already modded yeah yeah they
work like 45 I had a modded GameCube man
from Vietnam do you think you're better
than me yeah yeah it's my story why are
you taking my Spotlight you just one up
at me now Jesus Christ
where did you get you got it from
Vietnam yeah so I actually brought Mike
and they modded it there and they had a
whole store that sold like copied discs
and I was like whoa this is a crazy
thing and they can't catch you because
it's a different country there's no
nobody's like regulating it yeah so not
to be like perpetuating crime but even
here on OfferUp or Craigslist you can
get your electronics modded like you can
get your stuff like still solder it and
then they'll make it so you have a PSP
that has every game already built in
yeah I bet you time out I bet you Ryan
has like six [ __ ] illegal ways of
making money that he's just holding out
I know you got I remember the other day
it was the other week when you're like
dude you know it's like a sick ass
little flip everybody after the
snowboarding season just like [ __ ]
sells their [ __ ] it's like Goodwill and
stuff so you buy them for summer because
it's super common said who the [ __ ] if
you go to Goodwill in the summer he buys
all the snowboards and skiing material
in the summer and then he holds on to it
it's so [ __ ] because you got millions
of square feet that's not that's not a
scam that's smart you're using your
brain man it's like what are you trying
to one-up me again
this guy is sneaky on this guy huh it's
a constant one-upper yeah yeah we don't
like him dude
but Ryan so the ultimate test is you got
a guy that can get a black box for cable
I can still try to get a black Boxer
Gabriel or can you or can you give me a
handicap placard for my car see that's
actually kind of quiet do you know
anybody allegedly do you allegedly know
anybody I actually just learned that
asmo account says uh you can get a
handicap placard
yeah someone just told like uh it was in
San Diego the opener told me that he has
asthma he got a handicap placard for so
you just gotta start wheezing so Ryan
how do I get asthma oh funny you can
bring that up you want an inhaler or a
prescription this is oh this is Jean
Jack he's got another my handicap
placards here damn no that sucks so he
just Parks puts it like walks out just
he doesn't super capable I was like why
the [ __ ] does it count why the [ __ ] does
it count he's like well you know if you
have really bad asthma and you're having
an attack like in a grocery store or
some [ __ ] in your car is parked super
far away you might not make it but if
you're close then you'd be able to get
to your car at least I don't want to be
able to use it for street parking so I
don't have to pay the meter you know
what I mean oh yeah I mean it's a pretty
it's a pretty big violation if you get
caught looking healthy after parking in
one of them shits what if I'm asthma
what if you have a placard doesn't
matter
it's expensive it's uh I got caught
recently what happened no we don't need
to talk about let's focus on you parked
in a handicap got tickets didn't we talk
about this nah Okay so it was it was
when obviously not
um it was when [ __ ] the lottery was
like a billion dollars and then Nina was
like hey can we pull into the 7-Elevens
right outside of my house can you put
7-Eleven to get a [ __ ] lottery ticket
oh that's the one where you weren't even
really parked in dude okay so every spot
was already taken there was only the
handicap spotting from the 7-Eleven so I
pulled in real quick to drop her off she
got out the car she wasn't even in the
7-Eleven yet engine was still on I was
in the car behind the wheel I was about
to back up and then a cop pulled him
right behind me and locks me in no way
and then comes over he's like and I'm
like oh my God were you like I was just
dropping her off and then yeah of course
I explained the situation but do they
give off he still give you a ticket yeah
it's because you didn't have bucks
yeah that was my first thought I was
born
I was sleepy what are you guys thinking
don't [ __ ] one-up me that's not the
way to one up Harvest like he's like
what come on careful can be careful you
got to edit yourself out later no do you
guys remember back in um like the late
90s early 2000s when when Tommy Hilfiger
was the [ __ ] every all Asians were in it
and then some rumor went around saying
that Tommy Hilfiger didn't like Asians
wearing his brand yeah and we all
[ __ ] stopped was that true or not my
parents still bought it for me after
was it real though it was a GameCube I
think after that [ __ ] Tommy Hilfiger
ended up on like Ross racks and [ __ ]
real quick yeah it did but it wasn't
true it was that he was saying that
Asian the Asian market that's been
counterfeiting his stuff he said that
the counterfeits don't look good
what the [ __ ] dude what do you mean you
just they look great
what a [ __ ] dick bro you can't be
appropriate like talking [ __ ]
you're quicker to defend the counterfeit
Tommy than actual Tommy Hilfiger I got
ah bro I got a Lakers jersey in Bali let
me tell you right I actually had a Tommy
Hilfiger logo it did look counterfeit
I've seen it shut up
you know what sick when you go to China
and stuff like that um and you go to
their counterfeit markets because they
have like legit counterfeit markets
right there's uh there's three tiers of
counterfeit there's like if you pay like
really little money it like it looks
kind of counterfeit and then you pay a
little bit more you get like this and
then you pay a good amount where it's
almost like it's kind of an expensive
fake but it looks exactly because it
comes from the factory like it actually
comes from the [ __ ] Factory that
these like same designer Brands make
them and stuff like that and when you go
into these stores that have like these
kind of like obviously not name branded
stuff you go into these like giant like
[ __ ] warehouses go to the store and
then you go to the right person because
you have to like know these [ __ ]
people and then they bring out this like
little uh laminated menu that has the
the name brand stuff because they're not
obviously selling the name brand stuff
just like in front of everybody they got
to give you a menu and then you can
order from the menu and then come pick
it up in XYZ amount of time because you
get it from the factory it's [ __ ]
crazy bro even in Jiu Jitsu keys right
there's a really famous brand called
show your role and like that was like
the hottest [ __ ] ghee and they do
limited drops they're like the Supreme
of Jiu Jitsu okay they are dope actually
did the collab was undefeated very cool
right see if Anthony likes it then
they're pretty cool but like we knew
homies that would get the cheap ones in
like Bangladesh and [ __ ] and those were
[ __ ] just as good bro because they
all come from the same [ __ ] Factory
it's all the same Factory it's just one
logo and then the stitching is a little
different that makes sense so ask me if
I got some fake ones do you have any you
sell them
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]